annuler deux années de suite pour cause
de covin le feu d'artifice du 14 juillet
à tour el-arish n'aura pas non plus lieu
cette année cette fois il en va de la
survie des sternes de la loire et de
leurs poussins mais les oiseaux n'en
sont pas pour autant tirée d'affaires
vous allez comprendre dans ce reportage
d'hélène chapelet
cette année encore elles vont avoir la
tête grâce à l'arrêté préfectoral de
protection du biotope c'est stern vont
passer un 14 juillet au calme pour la
troisième année consécutive il n'y aura
pas de feu d'artifice tiré depuis les
bords de loire à tours une décision pour
protéger ces oiseaux migrateurs qui sont
en pleine période de couvaison une
volonté comprise par les tourangeaux
rencontré près du fleuve royal
laissant l'essentiel de garde est de
comme on dit la nature telle qu'elle est
de ne pas laisser les oiseaux sont fuir
à cause de ça on est un peu partagé
parce que les activités aussi des feux
d'artifice ça attire beaucoup de monde
donc le proposer à la limite tour nord
où tout sud où il n'y a pas forcément
des oiseaux crise qui couve les oeufs
alors je pense que le feu d'artifice est
une
institution une tradition qu'il faut
préserver mais la faune et la flore
également et donc trouver un autre lieu
pour tirer ce feu d'artifice serait une
bonne idée
en 2019 lors du dernier feu d'artifice
la ligue de protection des oiseaux a
observé le comportement des sternes
durant le spectacle pyrotechnique à
cause du bruit et de la présence de
nombreux humains les oiseaux adultes se
sont envolés délaissant leur nid et
leurs petits c'était une nuit qui était
relativement fraîches le 14 juillet en
2019 et donc tous les oeufs qui n'avait
pas encore éclos ont pris le froid et
donc les embryons n'était plus viable et
tous les poussins qui étaient encore
présents n'avaient pas la chaleur des
parents pour pouvoir les réchauffer et
en plus le stress engendré par les
détonations du feu ont fait que certains
poussant sont morts de crise cardiaque
ou bien se sont jetés à l'eau à cause de
la peur et ont voulu fuir en fait cet
endroit sauf que ce sont des espèces qui
ne savent absolument pas nager et donc
les poussins se sont noyés
malgré cette mesure préfectorale pour
sauvegarder l'espèce la nature pourrait
finalement venir tout gâcher la loire
devrait monter d'un mètre d'ici à
vendredi midi la plupart des oeufs et
des petits situés sur des bancs de sable
inondable devrait donc connaître le même
sort qu'en 2019